Okay. So we'll, should I just improvise
something? Sure. Hey, this is jad.
Before we launch into this
week's podcast, uh, I want to,
uh, make you aware of, uh, well our
friends down the hall, Brooke, my friend,
our friends, uh, on the media,
Brooke Gladstone is here with me. Uh,
having a new show coming out
that I'm, I think I might be in,
I'm excited to be in, but I'm
certainly excited about. So what is it?
You are going to be in
it? It's an episode,
although you don't want to say show
because on radio lab that generally means
that you're launching a whole
new style new enterprise. Yeah.
This is an episode on twitch,
which some people know as if,
as if it were part of their
family or like what? Yeah.
Is that something you need medication
for? So it depends where you're situated,
but what we are going to do is examine
how it came to be and how it points to
the future of where our culture's going.
And for the people who don't
know what is twitch. Most people,
if they've ever heard of it,
they know it's about watching and
commenting in real time on people playing
video games.
No
trap rap. And you guys,
from what I hear profile one
of these twitch superstars,
the main character in that story is
Ninja who makes something like half a
million dollars a month.
What bought on twitch? Yes.
Through contributors who say say this out
loud or point to me mention my name is
online
and at the same time
he's playing the game.
He's even giving advice to
young boys with girlfriends.
Don't act like, you know, don't make,
don't make her seem, it's like her fault.
You just need to be like
they like we need have,
we need to have a talk and be like,
don't worry, everything's fine, you know,
reassure that. But then you just need to
be like, I really feel like I'm trying,
like putting in more effort in
this relationship. And then like,
then I feel like you are, and I
want him to I and then just be like,
I just want to make sure that you're just,
you're just as invested in this as I am.
I think it's something
new. I want to hear that.
Well, thank you. Thank you for letting
me in the top of your shell. Absolutely.
So a twitch on, on the media,
on the media.org. Check it out.
I'm in there. It's going to be
amazing, but not just because of me,
cause of you Brooke. Thanks for
dropping in and Bob and Bob. Bye. Bye.
Oh wait, you're listening.
I adore listening to radio
lab radio from W N Y C E.
Hey, I'm Jen. I boom Rod. I'm
Robert Krulwich, Radiolab.
And today we have a story about
what we can say and what we can't.
And by the way, um,
there's going to be a smattering of
curse words here that we're not going to
bleep, I think makes sense.
Given the content of this story.
And also there's some graphic scenes
that, uh, if you've got kids with a,
you may want to mess with
this one out. Yeah. Anyway,
the story comes to us from producers,
Simon Adler. So let's start,
can we start in 2008? Sure. How about
with a song? Yes, please. [inaudible]
[inaudible] man, Facebook
sees Sarah Oppressive way,
rise up, rise and put
bad guy. Shake chairs,
red now.
So, uh, December 27th, a
sunny Saturday morning, uh,
this group of young to middle aged
women gathered in downtown. Yeah.
Palo Alto, cyberspace free.
[inaudible]
they're wearing these colorful hats and
are thinking and swaying directly in
front of the glass toward headquarters of,
yeah, it's nice. And one or graphics.
Facebook is their phone call.
Yes.
It was a humble gathering of
a few dozen women and babies.
That right there. Are you,
the organizer tonight is one of
the organizers of the gathering,
Stephanie Mujer.
And what, what are you calling the
event? Um, it's a Facebook nursing
nursing as in like breastfeeding.
The intent was really just to be visible
and be peaceful and make a quiet point.
What a, what point were
they trying to make?
Well, uh, so Stephanie, in this
group of mothers, you know,
they were on Facebook as many people
were and they'd have photos taken of
themselves occasionally
breastfeeding their babies.
They wanted to share with their
friends what was going on.
So they would upload those
photos to Facebook and these
pictures would get taken
down and they would receive a warning
from Facebook for uploading, um,
pornographic content. And people were
really getting their backs up over this.
They wanted Facebook to stop taking
their photos down to say that, well,
nudity is not allowed.
Breastfeeding is exempt, period
and goes back [inaudible]
now what Stephanie couldn't have
known at the time was that this
small,
peaceful protest would turn out to be
this morning of face off on Facebook.
One of the opening shots.
Facebook triggered a Hornet's nest
in what would become a loud fuck you
Facebook. [inaudible] Facebook
Rawkus fuck you, Facebook, fuck you.
And global battle in battles. Facebook
CEO's book today playing defense.
And now I'm not talking about all the
things you've recently heard about Russian
interference in election
meddling or data breaches, but,
but rather something
that I think is a is deep
then both of those free speech, Facebook,
his minute Hughes are facilitating. Yeah,
violence against Rohingya Muslims we
can say and what we can't say but again,
Facebook vine,
this iconic photographs we can see and
what we can see Mueller rape kids in
front of people.
Do you want to close this one?
Hear me.
[inaudible] you are fucking theses yet.
Thank you Mr Chairman. Uh, Mr
Zuckerberg got gotta ask you,
do you subjectively
prioritized or censor speech?
Congresswoman,
we don't think about what we're doing
is censoring speech but there are types
of, what really grabbed me was,
was discovering that underneath
all of this is an actual rule book,
a text document that dictates
what I can say on Facebook.
What you can say on Facebook and what
all 2.2 billion of us can say on Facebook
for everyone in the entire
globe for everyone. One,
one set of rules that all 2.2
billion of us are expected to follow.
This is an actual document.
It's a digital document, but
yes, it's about 50 pages.
If you print it off and a in bullet
points and if then statements,
it spells out sort of a first
amendment for the globe,
which made me wonder like
what are these rules?
How were they written? And can you even
have one rule book? Right, exactly.
And so I,
I dove into this rule book and dug up
some stories that really put it to the
test.
Hm. Okay. Yeah, I'm interested in
with the stories we're going to hear.
We are going to three ish.
Three ish. Okay. Okay. Alright.
I'm particular interested in the ish,
but let's go ahead with the first one.
Well, so, uh, let's start back,
uh, on that morning in 2008,
the morning that you could
argue started at all,
right? Right. Cause
building right behind
those protesting mothers,
there was a group of Facebook employees
sitting in a conference room trying to
figure out what to do. Um, cool. So if I,
so I'm just gonna switch to just read.
So I was able to get in touch with a
couple of former Facebook employees,
one of whom was actually in
that room at that moment.
And now neither of these two were
comfortable being identified,
but they did give us permission to quote
them extensively. How's that? Well,
they'll take work for you. It sounded
great. Um, cool. Just so we have it,
let's, so what you're
going to hear here is,
is an actor we brought in to read quotes
taken directly from interviews that we
did with these two different former
Facebook in place. [inaudible] all right,
ready? So at the time when I joined them,
there was a smaller group, 12 of us,
mostly recent college grads who were
sort of called the site integrity team.
Again, keep in mind, this
was in the early [inaudible]
thousands seismic changes this
week in the Internet hierarchy.
This was like the deep, dark past.
My space.com is now the most visited
website in the U. Of course, Facebook
had somewhere in the
neighborhood of 10 million users.
We were smaller than my space. The
vast majority of them, college kids.
And so in those early days,
those 12 people, they would,
they would sit around in
a sort of conference like
room with a big long table,
each of them in front
of their own computer
and things would come up onto
their screen flagged to Facebook.
And I'm like
meaning like I a user saw something
that I thought was wrong. Okay.
Exactly like a reporting a piece of
content that you think violates the
community standards.
This is Kate clonic,
she's a professor of law at St John's
and she spent a lot of time studying this
very thing and,
and she says in those early days what
would happen is a user would flag a piece
of content and then that content
along with an alert would,
would get sent to one of those
people sitting in that room.
It would just pop up on their screen.
Most of what you were seeing was either
naked people blown off heads or things
that there was no clear reason
why someone had reported,
cause it was like a photo of a golden
retriever and people are just annoying.
And every time something
popped up onto the screen,
the person sitting at that computer
would have to make a decision whether to
leave that thing up or take
it down. And at the time,
if you didn't know what to do, you
would turn to your pod leader who was,
you know,
somebody who had been around nine months
longer than you and ask what do I do
with this?
And they would either have seen it
before and explain it to you or you both
would know and you'd Google some things.
It really was just kind
of an ad hoc approach.
Was there any sort of written standard
or any common standard? A well kind of,
they had a set of community standards
that they, at the end of the day,
they were just kind of, that was one
page long and it was not very specific.
Sorry. The, the guidelines were really
one page long. They were one page long.
And basically all this page said
was nudity is bad, so is Hitler.
And um, if it makes you
feel bad, take it down.
And so when one of the people sitting
in that room would have a breastfeeding
picture pop up on the screen in
front of them, they'd be like,
I can see a female breast.
So I guess that's nudity.
And they would take it down until
rise up, fight for the
rights to have breastfeeding.
Anyway, now a dozen or so people in
front of their offices on a Saturday.
It probably wasn't causing Facebook too
much heartache, but I thought, you know,
hey, we have an opportunity
here with, you know,
over 10,000 members in our group.
According to Stephanie Mirror.
Those protesters were just a tiny fraction
of a much larger online group who had
organized, ironically
enough through Facebook.
So to coincide with the live protest,
I just typed up a little blurb encouraging
our members that were in the group to
do a virtual nurse in a
virtual nursing, right.
What we did, they posted a message
asking their members to for
[inaudible],
changed their profile Avatar to an image
of breastfeeding and then changed their
status to the of our group.
Hey, Facebook. Breastfeeding is
not obscene and it caught on.
A social networking website is under
fire for its policy on photos of women
breastfeeding their children.
12,000 members participated and the
media requests and started pouring in the
Facebook group call. Hey, Facebook.
Breastfeeding is not good.
I did hundreds of interviews for
print, Chicago Tribune, Miami Herald,
Time magazine, New York
Times, Washington Post. No,
the Internet is an interesting
phenomenon. Dr Phil.
It was a media storm
and eventually perhaps as a result
of our group and our efforts,
Facebook was forced to get much
more specific about their rules.
So for example, by then, nudity was
already not allowed on the site,
but they had no definition for
nudity. They just said no nudity.
And so the site integrity team,
the those 12 people at the time,
they realized they had to start
spelling out exactly what they meant.
It's precisely all of these people at
Facebook were in charge of trying to
define nudity.
So I mean, yeah, the first cutout,
it was visible male and female genitalia
and then visible female breasts.
And then the question is, well, okay,
how much of a breast needs to be showing
before it's nude and the thing that we
landed on was if you could see
essentially the nipple and Areola,
then that's nudity and it
would have to be taken down,
which theoretically at least
would appease these protesters because
you know now when a picture would pop up
of a mother breastfeeding,
as long as the child was blocking the
view of the nipple and the Areola,
they they could say, cool, no problem.
Then you start getting pictures that are
women with just their babies on their
chest with their breasts
bare. Like for example,
maybe baby was sleeping on the chest of
a bare breasted woman and not actively
breastfeeding.
Okay. Now what? Like is this
actually breastfeeding? No,
it's actually not breastfeeding.
The woman is just holding the
baby and she has her top off.
No, but she was clearly
just breastfeeding the baby.
Well like it was before.
Well I would say it's sort of
like kicking a soccer ball,
like a photo of someone who has
just kicked the soccer ball.
You can tell the ball is in the air,
but there was no contact between
the foot and the ball in that moment
potentially. So although it is a photo
of someone kicking a soccer ball,
they are not in fact kicking
the soccer ball in that photo.
That's a good in this,
this became the procedure or the protocol
or the approach for all these things
was we have to base it purely
on what we can see in the image
and so it didn't allow that to stay up
under the rules because it could be too
easily exploited for other types of
content like nudity or pornography.
W We got to,
the only way you could objective only
say that the baby and the mother were
engaged in breastfeeding is if the baby's
lips were touching a woman's nipple.
So they included what you could
call like an attachment clause.
But as soon as they got that rule in
place, like you would see, you know,
a 25 year old woman and a
teenager looking boy. Right.
And like what the hell is going on there?
Oh yeah.
It gets really weird if you like start
entering into like child age and it
wasn't even gonna bring that
up cause it's kind of gross.
It's like breastfeeding
porn, is that a thing?
Are there sites like half
apparently. And so this team,
they realized they needed to have a new
duty rule that allowed for breastfeeding
but also had some kind of an age cap.
So, so, uh, so then we were saying, okay,
once you've progressed past infancy,
then we believe that it's an approval
Britt.
But then pictures would start popping
up on their screen and they'd be like,
wait, is that an infant? Like where's
the line between infant and toddler?
And so the thing that we landed on was
if it looked like the child could walk on
his or her own, then too
old, big enough to walk
too big to breastfeed. Oh that
could be [inaudible]. Yeah,
that's like a year old
in some cases. Yeah.
And like the World Health Organization
recommends breastfeeding until you know,
like 18 months or two years,
which meant there were a lot of photos
still being taken down within you know,
days.
We continuing to hear reports from
people that their photographs were still
being targeted. But
Facebook did offer a statement saying
that's where we're going to draw the
line@facebookusingbudgetingonitpolicyandkeepinmindthroughthiswholeepisodeisthisperhapsthenextbigthingandthefacebook.com
the company was growing
really, really fast.
It seems like almost
everyone is on it and it's,
and there just got to
be a lot more content.
When we first launched we
were hoping for, you know,
maybe 400 500 people and now we're at
100,000 so who knows where we're going
now? [inaudible] more people
are joining Facebook every day,
60 million users so far with a projection
of 200 million by the end of the year
and now more people on Facebook
than the entire us population.
Not just within the United States,
but also it was growing rapidly.
More International, you know,
you were getting spokes in India,
India and Turkey. Facebook,
Facebook is going to ran this.
Butch was getting big throughout
the EU. Korea's joined the Facebook.
So they have more and more content coming
in from all these different places,
in all different languages.
How are we going to keep
everybody on the same page?
And so once they saw that this was the
operational method for dealing with this,
creating this like nesting
set of exceptions and rules
and these clear things
that had to be there,
had to not be there in order to
keep content up or take it down,
that I think became their procedure.
And so this small team at Facebook
got a little bigger and bigger,
jumped up to 60 people and then a hundred
and they set out to create rules and
definitions for everything. Huh?
Can we go through some of sort of the
ridiculous examples? Let's go over here.
Hey, so Gore Gore, you mean
violence? [inaudible] yes.
So the Gore Standard was
headline. We don't allow
graphic violence and Gore.
And then the shorthand definition they
used was no insides on the [inaudible].
No guts, no blood pouring out
of [inaudible] was a separate
issue. There was, uh,
an excessive blood rule and to come
up with rules about bodily fluids,
semen for example, would be
allowed in like a clinical setting.
But like what does a clinical
setting mean? And you know,
does that mean if
someone is in a lab coat?
Hmm. At one of my favorite examples
is like, how do you define art?
Because as these people are moderating,
they would see images of naked people
that were paintings or sculptures come up.
And so what they decided to do is
say art with nakedness can stay up.
Like it stays up if it is made
out of wood made out of metal.
Made out of stone. Really? Yeah.
Because how else do you define
art? You have to just be like,
is this what you can see with your
eyeballs? And so from then on,
as they run into problems,
those rules just constantly get
updated or constant amendments. Yeah.
Constant amendments,
new problem, new rule, another
new problem. Updated rule.
In fact, at this point, they,
they're amending these rules up
to 20 times a month. Wow. Really?
Yeah. Take for example those
rules about breastfeeding.
In 2013 they removed the attachment clause
so the baby no longer needed to have
its mouth physically touching the
nipple of the woman. Oh. And in fact,
uh,
one nipple and or areola
could be visible in the photo,
but not too only one.
Then 2014 they make it so
that both nipples or both
Areola may be present in the
photo. So this is what happens in American
law all the time. It's very thing.
Yes. Yeah, yeah. You know, it
sounds a lot like common law.
So common law is the system dating back
to early England where individual judges
would make a ruling, which
would sort of be a law,
but then that law would be amended
or evolved by other judges.
So the body of law was sort of constantly
flushed out and face of new facts.
Literally every time this team at Facebook
would come up with a rule that they
thought was airtight come, plop something,
something would show up that day
that they weren't prepared for that,
that the rule hadn't accounted a, as
soon as you think, yeah, this is good.
Like the next day something
shows up to show you. Yeah,
you didn't think about this. For example,
sometime around 2011 this
content moderator is, is,
is going through a queue of things
except reject, except escalate.
Except
she comes upon this image.
Oh my God.
The photo itself was a teenage girl,
African by dress and skin
breastfeeding a goat of baby goats.
Hm. And the moderator throws their hands
up and says, what the fuck is this?
And we googled breastfeeding goats
and found that this was a thing.
It turns out it's a survival practice
according to what they found.
This is a tradition in Kenya
that goes back centuries,
that in a drought,
a known way to help your herd through
the drought is to, uh, if you,
if you have a woman who's lactating, to
have her nurse, the kid, the baby goat,
along with her human kit. Hmm. And
so there's nothing sexual about it,
just good for business.
Good. And theoretically,
if we go point by point through
this list, it's an infant.
It's SORTA could walk. So maybe
there's an issue there, but there,
there's physical contact between
the mouth and the nipple. But,
but obviously breastfeeding
as we intended anyway,
meant human infants. And so in that
moment, what they decided to do is,
uh,
remove the photo and there
was an amendment and asterick
under the rule stating
animals are not babies. We added
that. So in any future cases,
people would know what to do,
who they removed. They, they,
they discover it was culturally
appropriate and a thing that people do.
And they decide to remove the photo.
Yeah. That outraged individuals,
our editors who are in wheeler. Why?
Why didn't we make an exception?
Because because when a problem grows large
enough, you have to change the rules.
If not, we don't, this was
not one of those cases.
The juice wasn't worth the squeeze. And
like if they were to allow this picture,
then they'd have to make some rule
about when it was okay to breastfeed and
animal and when it wasn't okay.
This is a utilitarian document.
It's not about being
right 100% of the time.
It's about being able
to execute effectively.
In other words,
we're not trying to be perfect here and
we're not even necessarily trying to be
100% just or fair. We're just
trying to make something that works.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven,
eight and when you step back and look at
what Facebook has become like from 2008
to now in just 10 years,
Simon, um,
I've just arrived at the
Accenture tower here in Manila.
I don't know how many
floors. It is one too
idea of a single set of rules that
works that can be applied fairly. Yes.
Just a crazy, crazy concept.
Just 1516 or 17
they've gone from something like
70 million users to 2.2 billion.
It's hard to take camp. I
would say it's about 30 floors.
They've gone from 12 folks sitting in a
room deciding what to take down or leave
up to somewhere around 16,000 people.
So there's a floor in this building where
Facebook supposedly outsources content
moderators.
And so around 2010 they decided to start
outsourcing some of this work to places
like Manila where you just heard
reporter Aurora almond drawl as well as,
I mean,
I would guess that there are thousands
of people in this building Dublin where
we sent reporter Gareth's stack Oh,
can see in where they get their
delicious Facebook treats cooked.
Everybody's beavering away.
And we sent them there to try to talk
to some of these people too for living,
sit at a computer and collectively click
through around a million flagged bits
of content that pop up onto their
screen every day. Wow. What a,
I'm just curious. Like
what's, what's that?
Well, um, can I ask you some questions?
[inaudible] we'd found out
pretty quickly the work floor.
None of these folks are willing to
talk to us about what they do. Um,
so there's a lot of, uh,
running away from me happening.
Hey, let's sir, sorry to bother you. Do
you guys work in Facebook? I'm sorry.
You have to work in Facebook anytime. I,
sorry to bother you. Do you reconcile?
No. Sorry. Do you work in Facebook? No.
I mean like you just came out of
there. I know you're lying. In fact,
people wouldn't even admit they work
for the company. Like what's the,
is there something wrong about being
in navy? Like an NDA that they signed?
Well, yeah, so, so when I finally
did find someone willing, uh,
willing to talk to me, do you
want to be named or do you know,
or do you not want to be named?
I'd rather not.
That's totally fine.
You know, I'm just
kinda like the industry.
I don't want to lose like
up on this shit. Yeah.
He explained that he and all the other
moderators like him were forced to sign
these nondisclosure agreements
stating they weren't allowed to, uh,
admit that they work for Facebook.
They're not allowed to talk
about the work they do.
My contract,
I hated to prohibit any from tackler
about what content moderation was.
Why? Several reasons. One
is that up until recently,
Facebook wanted to keep secret what
these rules were so that they couldn't be
gamed. At the same time, it,
it creates a sort of separation
between these workers and the company,
which if you're Facebook, you might want,
yeah, I, I knew I signed up
to monitor with graphic images
just given the nature of the job.
Right. You know, I
didn't really, you know,
you don't really know the impact that
that's gonna have on you until you got
through it.
This guy talked to he,
he got his first contract doing this
work several years back and for the
duration of it, about a year, he'd
show up to his desk every morning,
put on his headphones. Okay, click, click,
click, click, click, ignore, delete,
delete.
Case by case by case by case.
45 5,000 kids every day was just
image and decision, image decision.
Which five, 5,000 a day you just said.
Yeah. It was like, there
was a lot of cases. Yes.
He, he said basically he'd have to go
through an image or some other piece of
content every three or four
seconds. Wow. All Day long. All Day.
Eight hours a day.
Wow.
Well, if I can ask, what
kind of things did you see?
Oh, I don't know if this is even a,
I don't know if this is like
radio is worthy. Um, it's true.
I think the accelerated, uh, no
clicking through, he came
across unspeakable things.
Some had exploded into, you know,
get the little squashed by a tank to,
you know, people in cages
being drowned too. Like
a 13 year old girl. Um,
having sex with an eight year
old boy and it's not just one,
it's over. I know. Right. Oh, right. Over
when did you, did this like keep
you up at night or did you did this
absolutely, absolutely 100%. Um,
and kept me up at night, uh,
catch himself thinking about these
videos and photos when he was trying to
relax. He had to start avoiding things.
Yeah, there were, there were specific
like movies that I couldn't watch.
It was fine.
I can pay for the Clinton Terrell's no
one [inaudible] and I see it. I was like,
okay, turn it on. I was like, like,
heads were exploding. I was like, nope,
nope. I have to walk away.
And I just, I had to,
I chose it was too real. I saw that.
It's classic. Good. Yesterday
a different moderator I spoke to
described it as seeing the worst side of
humanity.
You see all of the stuff that you and I
don't have to see because they are going
around playing cleanup. Yeah.
What a job. Oh Wow. Yeah. And it,
and it's worth noting that I'm more and
more of this work is being done in an
automated fashion,
particularly with content like a
gore or terrorist propaganda. Uh,
they're getting better automate
that. They, yeah, they, uh,
through computer vision they're
able to detect hallmarks of, of,
of a terrorist video or of a gory image.
And, uh, with terrorist propaganda,
they now take down 99% of it
before anyone flags it on Facebook.
Oh. But, uh, moving onto
our second story here,
there is a type of content that they, uh,
that they are having an incredibly
hard time. Uh, not just automating,
but even getting their rules straight
on and that surrounding hate speech.
Oh, good. Some more laughs coming up.
Well, there will be laughter. Oh really?
There will be comedians. There will
be jokes. Hey. All right. Okay.
Should we take a break and
then come right back? No,
I think we're going to keep going. Okay.
Testing one, two, three, four, five.
Testing. One, two, three, four, five.
I'm Simon Adler,
so a couple months back. I think it's
working great. We sent our pair of intern,
it's on the left 60 feet, Carter Hodge.
Here we go at this standing
room and lazy Gieger
tickets for tonight. Anywhere on the
guest list. Okay. To this cramped,
sorry. Narrow little comedy club.
The kind of place with
like a super, yeah, I know.
$15 smashed rosemary cocktails.
None of it. We do not need to get up.
And that is the fine high top tables.
The acs dripping on me, but still
kind of a die is good. Yeah.
Sent them there to check out someone else
who'd found a fault line in Facebook's
rule book,
deciding where to keep it moving right
along the next two you come to stage,
please give it up for Marcia Belsky.
Yes, I get so mad. I feel like
my personal into the city.
I was such a carefree Brat, you know,
I was young and I had these older friends,
which I thought was like very cool.
And then you just realize
that they're alcoholics
know
he's got dark curly hair
was raised in Oklahoma,
you know, and I think I was raised
Jewish. So when you're raised Jewish,
you read about Anne Frank a
lot, you know a lot, a lot.
And when you read about Anne Frank
like this, we'll get funny [inaudible]
how did you decide to
become a comedian? You know,
it was kind of the only thing
that ever clicked with me.
And especially political comedy, you know,
I used to watch the daily show every
day and back in 2016 she started this
political running bit that I think can
be called sort of a absurdist feminist
comedy.
No, a lot of people think that I'm like
an angry feminist. Um, which is weird.
This guy called me a militant feminist
the other day and I'm like, okay,
just because I am training a
militia women in the woods.
At first I just had this running
bit online on Facebook and Twitter.
She was tweeting and
posting jokes, you know,
like we have all the buffalo wild wings
surrounded, you know, things like that.
Eventually took this bid on
stage, even wrote [inaudible]
Hey, I'm older,
I tend to dive on my dad.
No, no, no. My Dad.
Anyhow, so about a year
into this running bit, uh,
Marsha was bored at work one day
and uh, logs onto Facebook. But, uh,
instead of seeing her
at normal newsfeed, uh,
there was this message that pops up.
It says you posted something that
discriminated along the lines of race,
gender, or ethnicity group.
And so we removed that post.
And so I'm like, what could I
possibly have post it? I really,
I thought it was like a glitch,
but then she clicked continue and they're
highlighted was the violating post.
It was a photo of hers. What, what
is the picture? Can you describe it?
The photo is me as look can
only be described as the Cherub,
cute little seven year old with big
curly hair and she's wearing this blue
floral dress.
Her teeth are all messed up and into
the photo Marcia had edited in a speech
bubble that just says kill all men. And
so it's funny, you know, cause I hit,
I hit, it's funny, you know,
I trust me, whatever. So, um,
I thought it was ridiculous because she
searched through her library of photos
and found that kill all men image and
I post it again immediately after like,
yeah. And it got removed again and
this time there were consequences.
I got banned for three days after that.
Then after several other bands
shoot forward, this is months later,
a friend of hers had posted an article
and underneath it in the comment section,
there were guys posting
just really nasty stuff.
So I commented underneath
those comments, men are scum,
which was very quickly removed. How,
how long did you get banned for
this time? 30 days. Wow. Yeah,
I was dumbfounded.
So there's a rule somewhere
that if I type men are scum,
you take it down. Yes.
And like what could it be?
Okay. And so Marsha called on
her quote militia of women.
Exactly. To find out like is this just me?
Female Comedians who are sort
of like mad on my behalf,
started experimenting,
posting men are scum to see how quickly
you would get removed and if it would be
removed every time.
And it was so they started
trying other words. Yeah,
to find out where the line was.
My friend put men are
dusk up that got removed.
Men are the worst removed to band.
This one girl put men are septic fluid
band,
but we're only at the middle of the saga.
It doesn't end there because
there's no, she's really like,
what the hell is going on is this sexism.
So I just start doing the most bare
minimum amount of investigating.
She's googling around
trying to figure out what these
policies are in. Pretty quick,
she comes across this
leaked Facebook document.
This is when I lose my mind.
This is when Mark Zuckerberg becomes my
sworn nemesis for the rest of my life.
Because what she'd found was a document
Facebook used to train their moderators
and inside of it in a section detailing
who Facebook protected from hate speech,
there was a multiple choice question
that said, uh, who do we protect?
White men or black children?
And the correct answer was
white men, not black children.
Not even kidding. Why we're
protecting black children are not.
That's not a good look racist.
Something's going on here.
There is absolutely some sort of
unaddressed bias or systematic issue at
Facebook.
Great. Hello, I'm doing well.
Thank you so much for being here.
Yeah, so not long after
sitting down with Marsha,
Facebook invited me to come out to their
offices in California and sit down with
them. I'm going to eat one cookie
and then, oh, they're little.
I think I get to typing.
Can I just get your,
your name and your title and I'm Monica
Bickert and I lead the policies for
Facebook. Monica Bickert is in
charge of all of Facebook's rules,
including their policies on hate
speech. And so I asked her like,
why would there be a rule that protects
white men but not black children?
We have, we have made
our hate speech policies.
Let me, let me rephrase that.
Our hate speech policies have
become more detailed over time,
but our main is you can't attack a
person or a group of people based on a
protected characteristic, a characteristic
like race, religion, or gender.
So this takes a couple of beats to
explain, but the gist of it is that, uh,
the Facebook borrowed this idea of
protected classes, uh, straight from us,
anti-discrimination law.
These are the laws that make it so that
you can't not hire someone say based on
like their religion, their
ethnicity, their race, and so on,
on Facebook. You can't attack someone
based on one of these characteristics.
Meaning you can't say men are trash,
nor could you say women are trash. Uh,
because essentially you're attacking
all men for being men. Oh, is,
is it the all, can I say Bob is
trash? Yeah, you can say Bob is trash.
Because as my story is explained to me,
the distinction is that in the first
instance, you're attacking a category.
In the second instance,
you're attacking a person,
but it's not clear that you're attacking
that person because they are a member
of a protected category. Oh.
So Bob might be trashed for reasons
that have nothing to do with him being a
man. He just might be annoying. Right.
Okay. So that explains why you take down,
men are scum, but why would you
leave up? Black children are scum.
Why would that not get taken down?
So traditionally we allowed speech once
there was some other word in it that
made it about something other than it
protected characteristic in Facebook
jargon. These are referred to as a, uh,
a non-protected modifier
just means literally nothing.
Give us an example of this.
So traditionally if you said,
I don't like this religion, cab drivers,
cab driver would be the non-protected
modifier because employment is not a
protected category. Huh? And so
what the rule stated was, uh,
when you add this non-protected
modifier to a protected category,
in this case the cab drivers religion,
we would allow it because we can't assume
that you're hating this person because
of his religion. And you actually
just may not like the cab drivers.
So in the case of black children,
children is modifying the
protected category of black.
And so children Trump's black
age is a non protected category.
Okay.
So a children becomes a
non-protected modifier and their,
their, their childness
trumps their blackness.
You can say whatever you
want about black children.
Whereas in the case of
white men, uh, you've got a,
you've got gender and race both
protected, you can't attack them.
That's just a bizarre rule.
I would think you would go the other
direction that the protected class would
outweigh the modifier. Well, they,
they made this decision as they explained
to me because their default was to
allow speech.
They were really trying to incorporate
or nod to the American speech tradition.
And so there's a whole lot of stuff out
there that none of us would defend as a
valuable speech. But didn't, didn't rise
to the level of stuff that we'd say,
this is so bad, we're going to
take it down. And uh, in this case,
their concern was we're all
members of like, you know,
at least half a dozen protected
categories. Like we all have gender,
we all have sexual
orientation. And if you may,
if the rule is that anytime a
protected class is mentioned,
it could be hate speech.
What you are doing at that point is
opening up just about every comment that's
ever made about anyone on Facebook
to potentially be hate speech.
Then you're not left with anything,
right? No matter where we draw this line,
they're going to be sad. Some
outcomes that we don't like,
there are always going to be casualties.
That's why we continue to change
the policies. And in fact,
since Marsha's debacle, they've
actually updated this rule.
So now black children are protected from
what they considered the worst forms of
hate speech.
Now our reviewers take how severe
the attack is into consideration.
But despite this,
there are still plenty of people that
is flawed because you are a social
network, including Marcia who, who
think this still just isn't good enough.
There are not systematic efforts to
eliminate white men in the way that there
are other groups. That's why
you have protected groups.
She thinks white men and
heterosexual should not be protected,
protect the groups who are
actually victims of hate speech.
Makes Sense. Well, yeah, because
in sort of hate speech, uh,
or thinking about hate speech
and there's this idea of,
of privileged or of historically
disadvantaged groups and that those
historically disadvantaged groups
should have more protection, uh,
because of being
historically disadvantaged.
And the challenge with that, uh,
that was presented to me was okay,
why the thousands new Japanese
reinforcements [inaudible]
in the 1940s
do cut off the Chinese
and pay and [inaudible]
you had Japanese soldiers,
tens of thousands of Chinese killing
millions of Chinese during World War II.
At that same time you had
Japanese American citizens,
a thousand persons of Japanese
ancestry, all of them would have to move
being put into internment camps.
And so we had to ask
ourselves the question like,
are the Japanese and historically
advantaged or disadvantaged group? Huh?
Japanese Americans pretty easy to make
a case that they were disadvantaged.
But in China it's a
totally different story.
And this happened at the
exact same moment. So you've
got two different places,
two different cultural stories and when
you have a website like Facebook that's
trans national community,
they realized where they decided that
ideas of privilege are so geographically
bound that there is no way to effectively
weigh and consider who is privileged,
who and
decided therefore that we are not
going to allow historical advantage or
historical privilege, uh,
into the equation at all.
[inaudible]
and I think it's very important
to keep in mind here Americans,
these moderators only have
like four or five seconds
come to make a decision [inaudible]
in those four seconds,
is there enough time to,
to figure out where in
the world someone is,
particularly given IP
addresses can easily be masked.
Go back where you came from.
Is it enough time to figure
out a person's ethnicity?
White children are better than
black children. On top of that,
we often don't know an individual's race
straight people stuck other categories
or even less clear like sexual orientation
and they,
they just realized it would be next to
impossible to get anybody to be able to
run these, run these
calculations effectively.
When we were building that framework,
we did a lot of tasks and we saw some
times that it was just too hard for our
reviewers to implement a more
detailed policy consistently.
They just couldn't do it accurately.
So we want the policies to be sufficiently
detailed to take into account all
different types of scenarios,
but simple enough that we can apply them
consistently and accurately around the
world. And the reality is anytime that
the policies become more complicated,
we see dips in our consistency.
What Facebook's trying to do
is take the first amendment,
this high minded,
lofty legal concept and convert it into a,
an engineering manual that can be executed
every four seconds for any piece of
content from anywhere on the globe.
And when you've got to move that fast,
sometimes justice loses.
That's the, um, that's the tension here.
[inaudible]
and I just want to make sure I
emphasize that these policies,
they're not going to please
everybody. They often don't.
Don't please everybody that's working
on the policy team at Facebook,
but if we want to have one line
that we enforce consistently,
then it means we have to have some
pretty objective black and white rules.
[inaudible] Coca-Cola,
[inaudible]
Oh, when we come back, those
rules, they get toppled.
[inaudible]
this is Danny from Denver, Colorado.
Radiolab is supported in part by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing public
understanding of science and
technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
hi, I'm Tracy and I'm a
reporter here at radio lab.
I wanted to take a quick second to tell
you about something that I think is
pretty cool that we make here
at the show. Besides the show,
we have a newsletter and I can
already hear you say big deal.
Everybody has a newsletter,
but ours is really,
really good and worth your time and
probably more worth your time than other
people's newsletters. So
here it is. First of all,
it lets you know when to
release a new episode.
And secondly there's this whole other
section of our staff picks and that's just
a list of things that the Radiolab team
have come across that were just really
excited about. And it could be something
like, you know Rachel keepsake,
our producer, you know,
she just worked on goon ads and she found
out about this really cool frozen zoo.
And then there's our other producer
Andy McCune and she kind of tells,
told everybody to Google horse mustaches
and it is definitely worth your time to
Google that. So go do that right now.
Or it'll be me talking about you know,
the joys or rewatching like my
favorite TV show living single.
So I hope you'll sign up. It takes
about 30 seconds and it's free.
So go to radiolab.org back slash
newsletter or you can text RL news as in a
Radiolab news two seven zero one zero
one that's r l news two seven zero one
zero one and thanks.
They are doors that once
open can never be closed.
W NYC studios and snap judge
with underground layer.
Scoop two is here,
starting this August every
week until Halloween.
Be Afraid, but don't turn out the lights.
Listen to speed wherever
you get your podcasts.
Chad, Robert Radiolab, back to
Simon Adler, Facebook free speech.
So as we just heard before the break,
Facebook is trying to do two
competing things at once.
They're trying to make
rules that are just,
but at the same time can be reliably
executed by thousands of people spread
across the globe in ways
that are fair and consistent.
And I would argue that this
balancing act was put to the test.
April 15th, 2013.
Hey Carlos. Rhonda, Carlos [inaudible]
get up. Thank you. We have some break.
We have some breaking news. Otherwise I
wouldn't cut you off so abruptly. Carla.
Monday the 15th 2013 just
before three in the afternoon.
[inaudible]
to pressure cooker bombs
with through the crowd near the
finish line. The Boston marathon
and
yeah, as sort of the
dust begins to settle.
Oh my God.
People are springing into action. Uh,
does one man in a cowboy hat sees this
spectator who, who's been injured,
picks him up, throws him in a wheelchair
and as they're pushing him through the,
this sort of ashy cloud, the,
there's this photographer
there and he snaps this phone
and the photo show is the runner in the
cowboy hat and these two other people
pushing this man who, uh,
his face is Ashen from all of the debris.
His hair is sort of standing on end and
you can tell that actually the force of
the blast and then the,
the particles that got in,
they're actually holding it in this sort
of wedge shape and one of his legs is
completely blown off and the second
one is blown off below the knee,
other than the femur bone sticking out
and then sort of skin and muscle and
tendons, it's, it's horrific. Meanwhile,
Hulu, CBS B area studio on the other
side of the country, x five new,
I remember snippets of the
day. Facebook employees,
we're clustering around several desks
staring at the computer screens,
watching the news break.
This has occurred just in
the last half hour or so.
I have memories of of watching
some of the coverage Schilling,
new images just released
of the Boston bombings.
I remember seeing the photo published
online and it wasn't long after that
someone had posted on Facebook
from the folks I spoke to.
The order of events here
are a little fuzzy, but
pretty quickly this photos going viral
and we realized we're going
to have to deal with it.
This image is spreading like
wildfire across their platform.
It appears to be way outside
the rules they'd written,
but it's in this totally new context.
So they got their team together, sat
down in a conference room. I don't know,
there was probably eight or 10 people
thinking about like should we allow it or
should they take it down
according to their rules? Yeah.
So if you recall the no insides on the
outside stuff inition that we had in
place, meaning you can't see like
people's organs or that sort of thing.
And if you can then we
wouldn't allow it. And in this,
in this photo you could see,
you could definitely see bone and so
by the rules the photo should obviously
come down. Yup. However,
half the room says no.
The other people are
saying this is newsworthy.
Essentially this photos being posted
everywhere else. It's important.
We need to suspend the rules.
We need make an exception
which immediately received pushback. Well,
I was saying that what we've
prided ourselves on was
not making those calls and
there are no exceptions. There is
either either mistakes or improvements.
We made the guidelines for moments like
this to which the other side shoots
back. Oh my God, are you kidding me?
Like the Boston Globe is publishing this
all over the place and we're taking it
down like, are you fucking
kidding me? Damn the guidelines.
Let's just have common
sense here. Let's be humans.
We know that this is important and
yeah, they're kind of there. Right?
But the reality is like if you say, well,
we allowed it because it's newsworthy.
How?
How do you answer any of the questions
about any of the rest of the stuff?
In other words, this is a
Pandora's box. And in fact,
for reasons that are totally
clear, team consistency,
team follow the rules eventually wins
the day they decide to take the photo
down. But before they can pull the lever,
word starts making its way up the
chain. And internally within Facebook,
according to my sources and executive
under Zuckerberg sent down in order,
we were essentially
told, make the exception
[inaudible]
I don't care what your guidelines
say, I don't care what your reason is,
the photo standards, you're
not taking this down.
Yes. Um, yes. That's what happened.
This decision means that Facebook
has just become a publisher.
W they don't think maybe they have,
but they've made a news judgment and
just willy nilly they've become CBS,
ABC, New York Times, Herald
Tribune, Atlantic monthly,
and all these other things all at once.
They just become a news organization.
Yeah. And this brings up a legal question
that that's at the center of this
conversation about free speech.
Like is Facebook a sort of collective
scrapbook for assault or is it a public
square where you should be able
to say whatever you want or, yeah.
Is it now a news organization
adds transparency?
I, let me get, let me get
a, I'm sorry to interrupt,
but let me get to one final question that
kind of relates to what you're talking
about in terms of what
exactly Facebook is.
And this question has been popping
up a lot recently. In fact,
it even came up this past April when
Zuckerberg was testifying in front of
Congress.
I think about 140 million Americans
get their news from Facebook.
So which are you, are you a tech company?
Are you the world's largest
publisher? Senator? This is,
uh, I view us as a tech company because
the primary thing that we do is build
technology and products that you're
responsible for your content,
which makes it of a
publisher, right? Well,
I agree that we're
responsible for the content,
but I don't think that that's incompatible
with fundamentally yet at our core
being a technology company where the main
thing that we do is have engineers and
build products.
Basically Zuckerberg and others
at the company are arguing, no,
they're not a news organization. Why?
What would be the downside of that? Well,
Facebook currently sits on this
little idyllic legal island where, uh,
they can't be held liable
for much of anything.
They're subjected to few
regulations, however,
we're where they to be seen in the eyes
of the court as a media organization
that could change. But setting that aside,
what w what really strikes
me about all of this is,
is here you have a company that
really, uh, up until this point has,
has been crafting a set of rules that
are both as objective as possible and can
be executed as consistently as possible.
And they've been willing to
sacrifice rather large ideas in,
in the name of this. They, for example,
privilege, which we talked about,
they decided was too geographically
bound to allow for one consistent rule.
But if you ask me,
there's nothing more, uh,
subjective or geographically bound
than what people find interesting or
important. What, what
people find newsworthy. Hmm.
And I'll give and I'll give you a, and
I'll give you a great example of this.
Uh,
that happened just six months after the
Boston marathon bombing when this video
starts being circulated out of
northern Mexico and it's a video of a,
of a woman being grabbed and forced
onto her knees in front of a camera.
And then a man with his face
covered, grabs her head,
pulled her head back and slices her
head off right in front of the camera.
And this video starts being spread.
I can't count how many times, like just
reading my Twitter feed, I've been like,
ah, you know,
like one person who came across this
video or at least dozens of others like it
was Shannon Young. My name is Shannon
Young. I am a freelance radio reporter.
I've been living here in Mexico for many
years now and then is covering the drug
war. In doing so years back, she
noticed this strange phenomenon.
It first caught my attention in early
2010 should be checking social media.
You know, you're scrolling
through your feed and you know,
you'd see all this news, people say, Nah.
There was this three hour gun battle
and intense fighting all weekend long.
Folks were posting about clashes between
drug cartels and government forces.
But then when Shannon
would watch the news, yeah,
that night, yes, I got [inaudible],
she'd see reports on the
economy and soccer results,
but the media wasn't covering it.
There'd be no mention of these attacks.
Nothing to do with the violence.
And so she and other journalists
tried to get to the bottom of this.
Reporters and Mexico City would contact
the state authorities and you know,
public information officer and
they'd be like, shootings, bombings,
what are you talking about? Nothing's
going on. We have no reports of anything.
These are just internet rumors.
The government even coined a
term for these sorts of posts.
The famous phrase at the time
was collective psychosis.
These people are crazy
because, you know, they didn't want
the situation to seem out of control,
but then the video was posted.
Yeah,
it opens looking out the windshield
of a car. On a sunny day,
the landscape is dry, dusty,
and the video itself is shaky,
clearly shot on a phone.
[inaudible]
so
[inaudible] go and taping
starts talking. And this woman,
she just narrates as they
drive along this highway
[inaudible] she can
phone from the passenger window to
the uh, to the windshield ideas,
not focusing in on these two
silver destroyed pickup trucks.
[inaudible] and she's saying, look at
these cars over here or there, you know,
shot up and [inaudible] oh
look here, look here. You know,
this 18 wheeler is, you know,
totally abandoned. It got shot up
at one point, she
sticks the phone out the window
to show all of the bullet casings,
littering the ground
and she just, you know, turned the,
the official denial on its head.
The government was saying there's no
violence here were cars riddled with
bullets. It was impossible
to dismiss. And from
then on you had more and more citizens,
citizen journalists uploading
anonymously video of the violence.
[inaudible]
low fi shaky shots of
shootouts. This member minutes,
he headings, I mean bodies hanging,
dangling off of overpasses
[inaudible]
to prove to the world that
this was really happening.
Let's say we're not crazy.
It's a cry for help. Yeah.
Which brings us back to that beheading
video we mentioned a bit earlier. Yeah.
That video of the beheading, a
lot of people were uploading it,
condemning the violence of the drug
cartels and when it started showing up on
Facebook, much like with
the Boston marathon bombing
photo, this team of people,
they sat down in a room, looked at
the policy, wait, the arguments,
and my argument was it was okay by
the rules during the Boston bombing.
Why isn't it okay now? Particularly
given that it could help?
Leaving this up means we warn hundreds
of thousands of people of the brutality
of these cartels, and so we kept it up.
However,
it's fucking, it's wow.
I think it's utterly irresponsible and
in fact quite despicable of them to put
people found out.
I have little neighbor kids that don't
need to see shit like that backlash
should they really any justification
for allowing these videos to people.
As powerful as David Cameron
weigh in on this decision today,
the prime minister strongly the move
saying we have to protect children
from this stuff. David Cameron tweeted,
it's irresponsible of Facebook
to post beheading videos. Yeah.
Especially people were really upset
because of what it was showing.
And so according to my sources,
some of the folks involved in making
this decision to leave it up were once
again taken into an executives
office. And so we went up and,
and there was a lot of
internal pressure to remove it.
And I'd go to my boss and say, Hey,
look, uh, this is the decision we made.
I recognize this is controversial.
I want to let you know why we made these
decisions. And they made their case.
There are valid and important human rights
reasons why you would want this to be
out there to show the kind of savagery.
And she vehemently disagreed with that.
They took another approach
arguing that if we take this down,
you're deciding to punish people who
are trying to raise awareness again.
She wasn't budging and just
didn't get, didn't get past that.
And ultimately, um,
I was overruled and we removed it
[inaudible]
just because there was pressure to do so.
The same people that six months prior
told them to leave it up because it was
news worthy said, take the video down.
Facebook this week,
reversed the decision and banned a video
posted to the site of a woman being
beheaded in a segment. Facebook
said quote, when we were [inaudible]
if you want the one from Boston and you
probably should have the one from Mexico
in, right. It was a mistake.
Yeah. I think it was a mistake because I,
I felt like like why do we have these
rules in place in the first place?
And, and, and it's not the,
it's not the only reason,
but decisions like that or the
thing that precipitated me leaving,
leaving. Yeah.
Not too long after that incident of few
members of the team decided to quit.
And what I think this story shows is that
Facebook has become too many different
things at the same time. So Facebook
is now sort of a playground.
It's also an r rated movie theater,
and now it's the front page of a
newspaper. That's all those things.
At the same time, it's all those things
at the same time. And in what we,
the users are demanding of them is that
they create a set of policies that are
just in the reality is justice means a
very different thing in each one of these
settings.
Justice would mean that the person in
Mexico gets told the truth in Mexico by
Facebook and the little boy in England
doesn't have to look at something gory
and horrible in England,
but you can't put them together
because they clash. Exactly.
So how do you solve that?
I don't know. I think it's important
to keep in mind that a, you,
even if you have the perfect
set of policies that,
that somehow manage to be just in
different settings and that can be
consistently enforced. The people at
the end of the day making decisions,
they're still, uh,
there's still people. They're still human
beings. Is the, is this working or no?
I can hear you. Yeah. Great. Okay.
At long last we figured it out,
Huh? Yeah. Yeah. They yearly.
I spoke to one woman who
did this work for Facebook.
I just wanted to be anonymous.
I don't want them to even know that I'm
doing it because they might file charges
against me.
Well, call her Marie.
She's from the Philippines where
she grew up on a coffee farm.
Yeah.
That's my father's Gra and I didn't
know that coffee was only for adults.
She said many afternoons
while she was growing up,
she and her mother would sit together
like outside sipping their coffee and
tuning into their short wave radio.
This is the voice of
America or Washington d C
and they'd sit there listening
to the voice of America silence.
I'm going to ask that we
all bow our heads in prayer.
She said one of her favorite things to
catch on voice of America were Billy
Graham sermons.
Billy Graham, one of
the great evangelists.
Oh father, we thank thee
for this love of God
that reaches around the world
and in gulfs all of mankind,
but then
fast forward 50 years to 2010 and Marie
is consuming a very different sort of
American media.
The videos were the ones that affected me.
There were times when I felt really bad
that I am a Christian and then I look
into this things.
She became a content moderator back in
2010 and was actually one of the first
people in the Philippines doing this work.
I usually had the night shift in the
early morning or in the at dawn from 2:00
AM to 4:00 AM
she worked from home and
despite it being dark out,
she put blankets up over the windows
so no one could see in at what she was
looking at. She locked the
door to keep her kids out.
Oh, you have to drive them away or I
would tell them that it's adult thing they
cannot watch
and she and the other moderators on
her team who lived throughout the
Philippines, they were trained on
the guidelines on this rule book.
There were policies that
we have to adhere to,
but some of us where we're
just clicking pass, pass, pass,
even if it's not really
passed, just to finish,
just to get through the content fast
enough and in some cases she thinks
a number of the moderators are doing
it as a form of retaliation for the low
rate
people were pissed at the low
pay. If I can ask how much, what,
how much were you making
an hour doing this?
As far as I remember it,
we were paid like $2
and 50 cents per hour.
Marie wouldn't say whether or not this
low wage led her to just let things
through, but she did say,
based on my conservative background,
there are things that that
I cannot look objectively,
so I reject many of the things that
I think are not acceptable really.
Of course
she said whether something was outside
the rules or not. If her gut told her to,
she just took it down.
Whenever it affects me a lot,
I would click the button now like it's
a violation because if it's going to
disturb the young audience
then it should not be there.
So like if there's a new person,
whether it was a breastfeeding photo
or an anatomy video or a piece of art,
I would consider it as pornography
and then click right away.
It's a violation. You took the line
to your own hands, you went vigilante.
Yeah. Or something.
So yeah,
I have to protect kids from those evil uh,
side of humankind.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
where does that leave you feeling?
They don't leave you feeling it.
This is just I'm at the
end. This is just um,
undoable. Um, I,
I think they will inevitably fail,
but they have to try and, and,
and I think we should
all be rooting for them.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
this episode was reported by Simon Adler
with help from Tracy Hunt and produced
by Simon with help from Bethel hop. Tay.
Big thanks to Sarah Roberts whose research
into commercial content moderation
got us going a big time and we thank
her very, very much for that. Thanks.
Also to Jeffrey Rosen who helped us in
our thinking about what Facebook is true.
Michael Churnis,
whose voice we used to mask other people's
voices to Caroline Glanville Rashika
booed, Raja Ryan Dougan, Ellen silver,
James Mitchell and Guy Rosen of course,
to all the content moderators who
took the time to talk to us and uh,
threw out to sign off. Yeah, I guess you
said, Huh? Ready? You want to go first?
Yeah. I'm Chad. I boom, rod. I
remember college. Thanks to listen.